de la ferraille et des branches d'arbres
entassées c'est ce qu'il reste des
magasins des maisons et des voitures qui
longeaient le bord de cette route à
rolling fork vive la plus touchée par
une tornade qui a balayé une bonne
partie du Mississippi jusqu'en Alabama
plus personne n'a de maison ici 17
résidence mais au-delà du matériel la
petite ville est aussi en deuil
sortir des cadavres des maisons comme
elle ils sont nombreux à être encore
abasourdi par la violence de la tornade
et des orages
ça va être difficile de s'en remettre
reconnais ce résident
nous ne savons pas où sont les gens ni
qui a survécu 17 commerçante qui a tout
perdu le gouverneur du Mississipi a
déclaré l'état d'urgence et promis que
toutes les ressources sont déployées
pour les personnes dans le besoin l'aide
se fera à long terme promethyl le
président Joe Biden a aussi appel à
l'agence fédérale de gestion des
urgences qui a déployé du personnel et
des ressources d'intervention pour
soutenir la recherche des disparues les
sauvetages et évaluer les dégâts
on reçoit des renforts de Vicksburg
Greenville Jackson même de l'Arkansas
dit ce Cherif d'autres petites villes
comme silver City ont été quasiment
balayés par les vents s'il est encore
difficile de savoir combien de personnes
ont été blessées ou manque à l'appel les
opérations de sauvetage se poursuivent
sans relâche pour tenter de retrouver
des rescapés ici Camille ferraizen
Radio-Canada Montréal